The first thing to understand before
looking at cars that drive themselves,
it's just how much of our lives cars
have become,
especially in the United States,
but really all around the world.
Um,
there are 33,000
Americans killed every year in car
accidents,
more killed in car accidents in the
United States.
Then in its entire history of war,
going back to the revolutionary war,
we have one point 2 million people
killed around the world.
It's one of the world's major diseases.
If it were a disease in terms of killing
people,
and we also give 25 percent of all of
our energy to personal transportation
and 25 percent of our greenhouse gases
are going to the car.
Now,
this is not true in Manhattan,
but in Los Angeles it's estimated that
more than half of the land in the city
belongs to the cars.
Garages,
it's driveways,
it's roads,
it's parking lots.
All of these things,
land that belongs to the car.
We have given up so much of ourselves
and we depend on the car for so much.
It shaped our cities that shaped our
lives.
The fact that now cars are going to be a
computer thing,
that the computer is going to be the
most important part of the car.
The thing that drives the car will be
more important than the engine and this
will be on the Moore's law curve.
We've talked about getting better,
not the engine getting better every
year,
but the important part that drives it
getting better every year.
The way computer technology,
network technology do.
We're going to rewrite really important
elements of our society when we make
transportation.
One of these computerized technologies,
so most people thought that cars drive
themselves or something from science
fiction.
I still routinely run into people who
say this is not in my lifetime,
20 or 30 years away,
but this is clearly wrong and is
becoming more and more clearly wrong.
As time goes on.
The most famous project and the most
advanced project has come not from a car
company but from Google and I worked
actually on Google's team for awhile and
building that vehicle so they have both
logged about 700,000
miles of driving on ordinary city
streets with their vehicles and they've
now just released in May of 2014.
They have released a new vehicle that
they're building from scratch,
designing from scratch which has no
steering wheel in it,
no pedals.
You just get in and you've given it a
destination probably on your phone and
away it goes and takes you there and
that's the real game changer when it
comes out.
The car companies also are all working
on efforts.
Every major car company has announced
some sort of effort and Nissan and
Mercedes and Volvo have all announced
they'll be selling cars and about 20,
20 that look a little bit more like
traditional cars,
but what Google's car does,
it's a vehicle that can run without
steering wheel and nothing can run
unmanned and that's where it gets really
interesting because a vehicle that can
run on its own is a vehicle that can
deliver itself to you.
It's a vehicle that can refuel or
recharge itself without you having to
worry about it and it's a vehicle that
can store or what we used to call park
itself,
although it may mostly function as a
taxi and as a tax seed wouldn't even
park at all.
It would just go pick up the next person
that has to pick up.
So today when people buy a car,
they go into the car dealership and they
look for a multipurpose car.
They ask,
what car do I need for my life?
Because they think,
well,
I ski twice a year so I need an SUV.
Or even though I live in the city,
I needed to ask you for you to get me up
to the mountains every so often or the
number one selling car in America,
the Ford F 50 pickup truck,
which is not what most of those people
need,
but we all go and buy at least a five
passenger sedan,
a multipurpose car for all of our needs.
When you think of cars as fungible
objects almost,
that can be delivered on demand because
you pick up a cell phone and you asked
her car to come to you.
Well suddenly you don't have to get a
multipurpose guard.
You can get a car for that trip.
The car that you need today,
the car that you need right now,
that is a very different car from the
cars we've made for the last century.
These big fat,
boxy things.
This is a car most of the time for one
person because almost all your trips are
alone.
Sorry.
Unless you're a very friendly person.
They're alone and they're just short
trips across town,
but we buy a car that's able to take
five people,
hundreds of miles and that's very
wasteful.
It's very energy inefficient and it
takes a lot of space on the road too,
so if most trips come in,
little small electric vehicles in
particular that are good enough for one
person or two people face to face and
they have a desk in them and a screen so
that you can work or watch videos and do
things and takes no time.
It's a very different vision of
transportation and it's a much lower
energy provision of transportation,
particularly as you enable electric
vehicles.
Now today,
people don't buy electric vehicles that
much.
They buy some,
certainly some,
some press being made about it,
but it's.
It's really a small portion of the car
market and they are worried that the car
will run out of range or it'll take
hours to recharge it when they're done.
They don't want to hassle with plugging
it in,
but a robot doesn't care about any of
those hassles and the robot doesn't care
about anything and because of that you
can get a vehicle that is electric
because you don't care about the range.
You don't care about the powertrain at
all,
so very different from the way cars are
sold today,
so we have lots of small efficient
vehicles.
These vehicles are so efficient that
they don't just beat out.
The cars were writing in now they beat
up the trains and the buses.
Even in Manhattan,
even in Japan.
That's how efficient small,
lightweight electric vehicles can be at
carrying people in terms of energy use
to send a person a mile.
So this would mean that the United
States would no longer have to import
oil from overseas and you've probably
seen there's a pesky habit that the US
has.
They're going to war over the oil
imports from overseas.
Be Very nice habit to be broken of.
It also means reducing greenhouse gas
emissions by $200,
million tons.
It means getting rid of all the parking
lots we have in our cities because if we
don't have to store vehicles in the same
way,
suddenly there's a bonanza in so many
towns,
maybe not the dense downtown part,
but all of the surrounding territory
where so much of that land is parking
lots and for cars.
Suddenly we're going to turn some
parking lots into park land.
That's going to be pretty nice.
We also have tricks to deal with
congestion,
and that's pretty big.
If you invest in real estate,
you probably have heard a mantra that
says the value of real estate is based
on three important factors,
right?
It's an old joke.
Really?
Location,
location and location.
We're going to change what location
means because transportation is really
what locations about.
It's having a short trip by either on
foot or on wheels or in transit or other
things to the things in your life that
you need to get to in the shops and the
people in the work.
The whole nature of retailing is going
to change because we're also going to
build delivery robots that never carry a
person and they're small and they're
very,
very cheap and they can get you anything
in 30 minutes,
not just a pizza.
And now we do have a society that's the
side of the pizza is the most important
thing in the world.
You have to be able to get it in 30
minutes,
no matter when,
no matter where you are,
but what,
if you can get anything cheaply in 30
minutes,
what does that mean for shopping,
for retailing,
for how we use goods,
how we own goods.
It's going to change a lot more of our
lives and people think to have cars that
are smart in this way.
A lot of people want to know when this
is going to come out and uh,
uh,
you know,
I make jokes about naming a specific day
and time.
Uh,
so we've seen forecasts for many
different companies.
Um,
Sergei Brin first said Google,
he thought would have cars and people's
hands in 2017,
um,
widespread deployment.
Not then,
but what's happening in the later part
of this decade and real deployment in
the early part of the 20 slash 20 a,
the car companies that have said 20 20th
sort of their target year,
most of them have said that although
tesla,
because Elon Musk,
the CEO of Tesla,
has the largest testicles of anyone in
silicon valley.
He said,
I'm a,
he thinks he's going to have a car in
2016.
We'll see if he delivers on that.
Volvo has also said they'll have cars
running around their headquarters town
in the hands of civilians in 2017.
So there's a lot of people willing to
make predictions for really quick
delivery.
Now,
will they spread like wildfire,
like smartphones or will they spread
like electric cars were really,
really slowly?
Well,
I'm betting on more like smartphones.
Um,
but that's not a bet that anyone can
promise the answer to a.
we're not talking about vehicles that
will be perfect.
It would be Hubris to suggest they could
be perfect.
There will be accidents,
there will be injuries,
and there could unfortunately even be
fatalities.
And we do have a strong fear of being
hurt by machines and good reason.
It's something to be afraid of,
but the social question is,
if you don't like being killed by robots
and you'd rather be killed by drums
because that's what's happening today.
Forty percent of the fatalities on the
roads here are a have drinking involved
in them and robots for better or worse,
very rarely drink a.
they'll make mistakes,
but for different reasons.
And so as a society,
it's an interesting question,
something you're very scared of,
but which is actually safer on the grill
whole.
It's nobody's going to release this
technology until they've got the
evidence to themselves,
to their lawyers,
to the public,
that it's doing a better job than people
are at driving.
So you've got something that is better
than people,
but it's more frightening.
And you could indeed see societies
jumping back from that.
However,
whichever country decides to jump back
on,
another country will jump in and there
are many countries which can change
their laws and their liabilities and
their rules very quickly in a way that
the United States may be can't.
And so there will be global competition
to see who rules the new car industry
and I really mean the car industry.
There is um,
our lesson that we teach over in silicon
valley about what's called disruptive
technology and when we go through
disruptive change and the technology,
it's very uncommon for the big players
from the earlier generation to make it
through to the new world.
And how many of you are using a Kodak
Camera,
for example?
Not too many.
So I fear for the car companies because
they will die.
Some of them as we move to this new
world and the places where cars are made
may shaft,
you know,
Detroit has a big challenge in front of
it and it's going to face against
wherever the new industry comes from.
But Japan,
Korea,
Germany,
they also need to be afraid and they're
the centers of car manufacturing today.
But politicians actually are aware of
this and they're interested in seeing
ways to,
to make sure that their economy becomes
dominant in this world.
And that's why they've already passed
laws in several states.
And then in other places around.
Yeah.
The
world to enable this technology rather
than slowing down.